hier aujourd'hui et demain ne se
succèdent pas ils sont connectés dans un
cycle sans fin il y a quelques semaines
dans la petite ville de winden
un adolescent de 15 ans a disparu dans
des circonstances mystérieuses îles
l'inquiétude des habitants est montée
d'un cran depuis la disparition d'un
second enfant
aucune trace rien c'est comme s'ils
s'étaient volatilisés tout est
exactement comme il ya trente trois ans
tous répètent
[Musique]
cette ville est gangréné et aucun de
nous n'était pas payée
[Musique]
il ya un assassin parinaud
dung
de pas ses influences évidemment le
futur
et le futur influence le passé lui aussi
tic tac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le début a faim et la faim et le début
[Musique]